alors Jean va s'enler vous êtes en
colère non je suis pas en colère j'aime
pas du tout votre façon de faire vos
reportages pendant 5 6 jours m'avez
suivi vous repassez cette histoire de de
PV en racontant n'importe quoi j'en bol
voà c'est tout vous allez vous allez
nous exp ma faire truc sympathique non
c'est pas du tout démarche c'est-à-dire
que le truc qui consiste à suivre les
gens pendant 5 6 jours en faisant des
risettes et tout pour faire des
reportage un peu de ce type là moi je
vais vous dire j'avais pas tellement
envie de faire cette émission et là
franchement c'est ça me donne vraiment
pas envie de continuer à discuter de ça
et on voit le niveau d'ailleurs c'est
la non je n'ai rien àé tout ça j'ai déjà
tout dit sur ce dossier et Monsieur
Berman c'est clos j'ai tous les éléments
et je trouve ça lamentable c'est une
histoire d' y a 5 ans qu'on m'a ressorti
notamment pour me nuire politiquement
j'ai 10 ce qu' était à dire et je trouve
ça assez minable de repasser sur cette
histoire sur lequelle j'ai répondu j'ai
apporté tous les éléments et je le dis
gentiment à notre sympathique
journaliste qui a passé 5 jours avec moi
quand en plus quand en plus on euh dit
des choses fausses ça c'est ça que
journaliste ne supectte pas en réalité
et non je n'ai pas l'intention de
revenir sur ce truc moi je vous ai j'ai
déjà répondu en janvier j'ai dit tous
les éléments j'ai apporté tous les
éléments et effectivement cette histoire
euh me navre certes mais j'ai tout est
réglé voilà c'est derrière vous c'est ce
que vous nous dites aujourd'hui très
bien juste c'est un portrait 10 minutes
qui vous est consacré on en parle
pendant une minute c'est de l'argent
public ça n'est pas anormal que le
métier journaliste nous normal c'est
vous savez quoi vous devriez revenir
dans C cas à chaque fois que vous voyez
ici un responsable politique sur ce qui
s'est passé il y a 20 ans sur ce qui
s'est passé il y a 15 ans et je vous
propose la prochaine fois que vous voyez
à la Jupé par exemple de revenir sur les
trucs qui s'est passé il y a 20 ans
voyez à chaque fois je trouve ça
incroyable et je vais vous dire avec les
verres vous avez un côté comme ça
insupportable parce que aussi bien quand
c'est le PS quand c'est l'UMP quand ce
sont les grosses formations alors là il
y a une tolérance absolu une sympathie
du système et quand ce sont les petits
partis et ben PAF et je vous trouve ça
honux
moable quand je fais une bê compris
parfois je vais vous dire il a une
dizaine d'années j'ai dû payer des
impôts en retard j'ai payé pénalités et
cetera et je respecte l'ensemble des
lois y compris quand je fais des bêtises
voilà c'est ça la réalité nous dire qui
est fa ce que Michel Saban à la région
de France
fa vous êtes ça n'est pas votre vérité
et vous nous pas ce'est pas ma vérité il
y a des faits tout simplement et ce qui
est été dit par Monsieur Berman
c'est fatait trs fac on peut rapporter
les propos du voisin il suffit président
de la région qui par-m il suffisait tout
simplement de me dire cela je vous ai
rapporté les documents les chèqus qui
ont été fait et je trouve ça lamentable
de faire cette façon de faire du
journalisme voilà c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire on dit les
politiques aujourd'hui ils ont plutôt
mauvaise réputation il y a une deuxième
catégorie de personnes qui ont très
mauvaise réputation ce sont les
journalistes notamment à cause de ça
donc voyz je pas qui aurit été grave ou
lamentable gempacer c'est de le dire et
que vous ne soyez pas là derrière pour
pouir rectifier si vous le souitez la
règle du je sa non non non non non mais
j'ai pas franchement j'aime pas du tout
cette façon de faire bon alors on va
continuer de discuter sur la SEM parce
que je trouve ça lamentable politique on
va parler de la semaine politique que
vous venez sous cet angle là je trouve
pas ça très intéressant bah votre
semaine politique si elle était très
intéressante elle
conc France je devrais faire comme Henry
gu et et partir
pardon si je suis pas loin de faire on
va en parler juste après de cette
semaine donc un peu particulière que
vous avez vécu Jérôme reviendra sur
votre réseau et Marc s'occupera du
déccriptageistique ne bougez pas nous on
revient
é
coms mais c'est bien vous l'avez dit je
pas non c'est pas important je trouve ça
honteux mais non mais c'est bien de
l'avoir dit fait mais Nonie là non non
j'ai pas du tout envie de faire des
émissions de ce type là
Jean-Vincent c'est important de discuter
avec nous de votre semaine mais non j'
s'lacer vous pouvez pas partir on fait
juste une enquête on pose les questions
y compris cell qui gratent pas plus sur
vous que sur sal de
personne